alrighty
are we live
yes cat tiger
what is up
we are live
and sounds like we can hear me all right
what is up
hello everyone hello hello hello hello
what is up it's
we're back
we're all back
love it love it love it
hello hello hello i love seeing the chat
i love seeing everybody here it's so
cool i'm so glad we're all back
let's uh let's make sure everything's
running smoothly
seems like it is
hey
what's up forsaken how's it going
all right looks like everything's doing
all right
yeah how's everybody been missing
missing the watch parties missing some
marvel content
love seeing the chat love seeing
everybody
awesome and we back i love uh
i love uh
love all that
[Laughter]
yo yo yo
yo boys this son bruno what's going on
i think everybody's ready for moon
knight i hope i hope you guys are hey
thanks for becoming a member oh my uh my
sounds not coming through the headphones
it's coming through the speakers
but hey moises thanks for
becoming a member for uh two months in a
row i gotta figure out how to do those
member streams
we'll be doing this since we're doing
those super soon members only videos
members only streams
uh i'll have some cool videos for
members only
um but yeah moon night guys
i think a lot of people are about to uh
really really like
how this show is
um i was doing my breakdown
for it and uh
just kind of going over everything and i
was like
yeah this show's about to be like
if they nail the landing
this might be the best marvel show uh
because it's pretty
it's pretty dang fire it's uh it's
pretty ding fire
all right we have about let's see it's
12 30
um
that means we probably have
probably like 20 minutes they usually
start like 10 minutes early right
moises thanks for that super chat uh am
i ready for doctor strange multiverse
madness
yes um at least i think i am
they've they've done like a really good
job at keeping it under wraps um
even disney has like talked to me about
it and has been like look we don't want
anything spoiled like anything spoiled
and uh
you know they can't exactly tell me what
to do
but
they did say that they are doing
oh they're taking a lot of measures into
making sure this stuff does not come out
and i gotta say a lot of stuff i haven't
heard i really i've talked about the
stuff that i have heard you guys if
you've watched my videos you've heard it
but
um
not too much you know past professor x
which they already showed um
has been in the illuminati which i've
been talking about for like a year now
uh probably more than that but you know
they
besides that nothing else is really like
like slipped out so
yeah hey
liam
llama's life stayed up till three in the
morning
completely happy yes yes yes yo jayanth
what's up man i am close to a million
million good to see you in here uh we're
getting it we're getting we're getting
close
we're gonna go moon night or mr night oh
you know
they asked
oscar isaac like which suit he likes
better and he said mr knight both look
pretty fresh um
both look pretty fresh
and
like the first episode the second
episode they're really good they're
really good and some of the scenes are
like
this is pretty cool this is pretty
different than than marvel studios has
shown us before it's pretty different
but
um i will continue to say that there's
some crazy things in the third and
fourth episode really really cool
thank you muhammad
ali rizvi want to see me get two million
i i hope i hope you do as well um i see
some people asking how the watch parties
work you know we used to um
we i used to be able to kind of show a
little bit of it on screen so we could
all follow along but now
uh disney has
blocked that somehow um on disney plus
if you try to screen record it or like
share the screen or something like that
like it doesn't work it just doesn't
show up it's just a black screen
so
now i'm just gonna time stamp it and uh
we'll just watch it together you'll
watch it on your disney plus account and
i'll uh watch it on mine and we'll talk
about it as it goes on we'll talk about
it after
hey what's up
guitar
what's going on i'm glad you're back as
well
let's see
moises kevin feige needs to make marvel
vs dc movie or zombie marvel i'm going
to watch more abuse movie on thursday
with my family
can you give us easter eggs from moon
night
uh in my breakdown yeah um i will say
there's a lot of
uh like egyptian mythology in it which
is pretty cool that's always kind of
interested me
but
i had to actually like
do some research on that
like i had to
i had to do a lot of research on like
egyptian gods there's this one part in
uh this episode i won't spoil it but
um
there's this one part where
a character says something
and i was like
what does this mean
because it's in a different language and
i like had to like
like figure out what he was saying
figure out what language it was and then
like translate it and keep in mind when
i get the screeners
they don't have subtitles as an option
um we don't get like all the disney plus
features and stuff like that it's just
like
you get a link and then there's a code
the code changes every minute
so when you go to log in it's like oh go
to this
see what the code is put the code in
unlock it and it's available for like
like two days so they're really really
straight and when you watch it like it
has my email address my name like
watermarked on it so like they would
know if i like
if i like released the footage so
um
it's not like i'm watching it like on
disney plus like this so
i
didn't have the luxury of being able to
turn on a subtitle and going what did he
say like i had to like listen like
really listen to what he was saying
so
oh we can see my cat
let's rock it she's sleeping
either her my other cat kyrie always uh
always sleep there uh i see
i see some people asking how many um
episodes is gonna air uh just one
and there it
it's 45 minutes long
i think was the run time of the first
episode i think the second one was like
54 minutes long
i could be wrong about that i can
actually check right now
i can let everybody know right now
uh
i see some
i see some people asking about
connections at midnight there really
aren't any um like they don't talk about
the blip they don't talk about like you
don't hear any name drops or anything
like that like you you really don't it's
uh
it's
it's pretty much its own project which
is which is pretty cool
alright episode one how long are you
45 minutes
44 seconds
yeah so the first episode is 45 minutes
i think the second is around 50 55
minutes
um
so yeah
i lost this
let's pull this up okay
uh what time is it for me
uh iron monkey you're in all land down
under australia right now it is 12 35
for me
and let's take a look here
let's go to marvel on disney plus
oh i don't even
i don't even see it on there yet
i might have to
might have to search this one where's
the search so keep that in mind guys up
there it is um
the first time
like something airs you're gonna
probably have to search for it it might
not show up if you're just browsing for
it so
if you can't find moon knight and i know
a lot of people are gonna say i can't
find i can't find it just search for it
search for it when will the episode drop
uh i would say in probably like
15 minutes
um
they
they usually drop like 10 minutes before
i forget the exact number there was like
an exact number it was like either like
11 minutes before nine minutes before
like something before like they usually
drop like red exactly on
uh
so we'll have to let's wait and see on
that one but uh let's see
cool we're up and going um
uh not that i've seen i see some people
asking about post credits i didn't i
didn't see any
um but i
can't remember if one time like the
screeners didn't show the post credits
um
yeah uh terra stone uh
one of my favorite episodes uh i i like
stick by three and four being like
because i've only seen one through four
three and four being
having some really cool moments so one
of those two for sure um
i like the first episode a lot
and i and i think it's really cool that
you meet stephen grant i i personally
really like how there's like you know
two people living in one body um
i i like meeting
stephen grant i like the character
stephen grant and that kind of makes the
first episode for me i really like the
first episode uh the second episode
is really really cool
it's different than the first you get a
little bit more
of some i don't want to spoil things
but uh uh three and four are really cool
and i'm really excited to see uh
five and six so
uh the acting is fantastic i see a a few
people asking that acting is fantastic i
actually think
oscar isaac was made to be moon knight
as weird as that sounds like
oscar isaac crushes it like
he's really good and ethan hawke is like
so perfect for this role
like so perfect for this role like i i
really do hey ritwick what's going on
how's it going
i haven't seen mr anderson in the chat i
see some people asking about him
i see some people
let's do this i'll put this out
here let's try that's over here sweet
cool cool
move this over here
get the chat over here
oh i'm gonna have to plug
this in or it's gonna die
there we go
all right guys just to let you know
if you spam
you're gonna get timed out
um f bombs and moon knight
i don't i don't recall and i think i
would remember that
they could remember that um
i i would say moon knight's a hero
but
not in the traditional sense you know
what i mean
but i would still say he's a hero
uh when does mr knight come spoil me i
would love to spoil you but if i spoiled
you i would be spoiling it for other
people as well so
i'm afraid i can't answer that but
you're about to find out uh
you're about to find out soon
soon
is it actual brutal i mean there are
some scenes where you're like uh wow
like
wow they kind of like they did that um
some are like cgi
so i think some will like some people
may say like oh that's brutal but some
may just like like i looked at it and i
was just like
it's cgi like it doesn't really bug me
dj vd thanks for the super chat to let
everybody know
appreciate it appreciate it
uh
augustia or garwall thanks for waiting
for the uh thanks for waiting for the
chat brian g hernandez yes supernatural
time uh
where where how many episodes are airing
right now just one
i so ritwik that's a good point they
gave 16 plus to moon knight so expect
like daredevil
type stuff i would say that's uh that's
fair to say that's fair to say um my
charger has seemed to drop to have
dropped out of my laptop
which is what i will be using
to watch moon night so one second
and i may have ran to use the restroom
real quick
all right
um what time does it start guys i'm
gonna say it starts in eight minutes
that's what i'm gonna say
let's see is moon night in the episode
yeah it's moon night
i feel like that's not a spoiler i feel
like i can say that it's moon night i
feel like i'm also not sinner and that
like really bugs me
but this is the best we're getting right
now
oh
if i spoil anything gonna come through
slap me you're gonna hit me like will
smith hit chris
[Laughter]
oh man
i can't believe that happened we won't
really talk about that but um
that was something huh
why
ah
the restroom when you pay rent
yo
have we had a no we have had a watch
party since spider-man no way home
because hawkeye yeah okay
i still forget about spiderman oil i
still can't believe we got it
i mean
it's so good uh okay i see some people
talking
um
if you search
you have to search moon night at disney
plus if you can't find it
hey cheeky bird
why did you watch the first four
episodes normally they only let you
watch first two yeah i'm not sure about
that you know sometimes
um
i think for
falcon and the winter soldier we watched
the first three there was one that we
got to watch the first three for oh
one division we got to watch the first
three four
yeah i believe so
yeah
i can't remember right now but there was
another one sometimes they only always
watch one sometimes they only let us
watch
two three and the times four maybe
they're experimenting i'm not really
sure um
i'm not gonna be surprised if they
eventually give us all the episodes of
something so
i don't know
six total episodes though so
four out of six
it's a lot of episodes you know good
question uh unfortunately i i don't
really have an answer for you but i
appreciate the super chat
i appreciate all right i'm gonna refresh
here just in case it's out already
nope moon knight trailer
what this is what it says when stephen
grant a mild manner gift shopped and
gift shop employee
becomes plagued with blackouts and
memories of another life
he discovers he has dissociative
identity disorder and shares a body with
mercenary mark spectre as steven slash
mark's enemies converge upon them they
must navigate their complex identities
while thrust into a deadly mystery among
the powerful gods of egypt and like i
said like i literally had to do like i
had to study
i had to study
like ancient egyptian mythology just to
kind of understand some things like
um in my for my breakdown because i try
i did it before
um and it's almost
done it's uh not officially done
but
instead of staying up till like 6 a.m in
the morning after these things like
doing a full complete breakdown i
decided that i uh that i'll uh do try to
do a little bit before and take my time
to do some research and like seriously
like there was a good chunk of time i
spent doing some research on
ancient egyptian mythology so
hey thanks ninja 07 appreciate that
let's uh let's not spam though i
appreciate that guys
but
um
yeah i have some mods in here and
they'll time they'll time you out if you
spam just so you guys know and if you
spam again after they time you out they
might ban you so we don't want anyone
banned
i want everybody to have a good time
here
speaking of time 12 46
is it out
i'm not out yet
hey ritwick remember for four months
thank you so much oh thank you so much
appreciate it
we love your work one of the reasons why
i go so deep in real marvel thank you
for everything hey super appreciate that
um and i've tried i've tried since we
had that one
problem with the members only stream
that turned out to be just everybody i
tried to do it again and it didn't work
i think i figured it out now
and i'll make a post about it soon also
be doing members only videos um so if
you guys want to become a member of the
channel if you go on your desktop not
your phone but your desktop to my
channel
there's a join button next to the
subscribe button and it just helps
support the channel and i'll be doing
some kind of like one-off videos that
won't be available to the public it'll
just be available to members
so
so let's try not to spam guys
i appreciate all the comments though
appreciate it all uh what i consider
moon knight uh anti-hero or hero
uh good
question based on what i've seen so far
i mean
you could you could say both like you
really could say both um
because it gets
that's a complicated question because
it's not just like one person right it
it's it's kind of two people it's kind
of three count conscious right it's
that's a complicated question because of
the dissociative identity disorder right
there's multiple people inside of one
person so you can't really say like
this person
is
good because there are multiple people
there if that makes sense you'll see as
it goes by you'll see as it goes by
because you'll see that the characters
they they really do have different
personalities
they really really do have different
personalities
so
uh we're getting pretty close
probably about i would say like two two
minutes two minutes and we'll uh we'll
be in it we'll be in it
um
and do you don't know when moon knight
is coming out uh is
is it does it not come out the same time
normally uh moises yeah man thanks for
super chat but yeah i i really
really hope this sets up the the
midnight suns let's crack open a g fuel
i have crash bandicoot g field today
if you guys drink gefil use code cosmic
you get a discount
i don't know what that means morgan
studios would i say that moon knight is
good
pro trail of did i'm not sure what that
means i'm sorry
uh
haha moon knight will i get to meet
blade i hope so i think it would be
dumb if all the supernatural sides of
things then eventually come together in
a midnight suns type of deal
hey navette kratz thank you so much for
that five dollar super chat with the
little is that a fox or a cat
either or i love it my cat is right here
she's sleeping
she's sleeping okay hello
hello c c of theories
i my day is good thank you for asking
but could you please stop spamming i
would i would appreciate that uh how
many episodes we're getting today one
and if i'm not mistaken
we will be getting it in less than a
minute now
if they do it like they've done every
other disney plush show so far
uh what do i say woof before oh man
that's a long story basically the short
version of the story is uh
the episode is out the short version of
the story is i set it for my fans
uh by accident one time
when i only had like 200 subscribers and
they wanted me to keep doing it so i say
it now to
kind of like
say that i remember my original
subscribers somebody should just give
disney all the marvel characters yes dj
wavy they should alright so
we're starting guys
it is out it is out it is out search for
moon night on disney plus
i forgot i need to do this i need to get
uh
let's do this
uh
timer
timer
is that how i used to do this
stopwatch
and then let's do this
no wrong screen
right screen that's how we're gonna do
this all right guys i'm about to start
moon knight we're gonna watch it
together we're going to talk about it
and i'm starting it right
now
i'm going to stop this time for like two
seconds three four five
six cool
oh i need to put
this in
all right
i think this part so
creepy
so creepy
creepy
so creepy
that's horrible
that's horrible oh
it hurts
thinking about it
we are in it
that's horrible
he's walking on glass
he's walking on glass he put glass in
his shoes
yes arthur haro is the main villain
we are in it
what am i hearing why y'all hear that
myself echoing
so from here
might be from here
marvel logo
moon night
oh for those wanting to make edits of
the so enchantrix
we're gonna have some good ones here
all right let's meet steven grant
ah
that's good stuff
quincy charles welcome to the cosmic fam
thank you so much for becoming a member
super appreciate that sorry i didn't
notice that sooner
but thank you so much
welcome welcome welcome
so the sand around his bed
it took me a little bit to like
realize what that was
it's in my breakdown again
little guess
he's just feeding his fish
one fin fish
he's just talking to his mom on the
phone
i love that he says that
oh i forgot to do something oh no
there we go
something wicked
see all this egyptian stuff here
i had to learn about all this
calls him stevie
this poor guy
i just feel sorry for him like this
whole first episode
laughs
your rascal
[Laughter]
dude his boss sucks
she's such a jerk
i hate her
so he's talking with his boss right now
and
she's just a worse
but he knows so much about ancient egypt
and she just doesn't even care
that's actually a question to hear
oh i would hate her come on
hey the movie couple
what's going on guys
movie coupler my friends wendy
this is the part
that's why he has all those restraints
and stuff
it is out it's out of thought guys we're
watching it right now
it's just like
the stephen grant side is like such a
nice guy and just feel
bad that he gets treated so poorly by
everybody
you guys should get a goldfish and david
steve
you guys should come on uh for a
discussion wendy
it would be cool to have you guys on
we do discussions afterwards
i like how like
when he was on the phone with his mom he
goes late as gay is
going back to putting all the sand and
stuff around his bed
taping the door
tying the chain back to his leg i mean
we've seen this in the in the trailers
how does he do that with his hands
i need to buy a
oh look it's the real rejects coming in
spreading lies
the any ad
i had to do some research on this
because he already talked about it and
then he talked about it again so i was
like
has to mean something
i got the movie couple in here i've got
the real rejects in here
[Laughter]
this is where it starts to get cool this
is where it starts to get cool
oh i didn't notice the glass next to him
before
on the floor i didn't notice that
i like how they call him it i like how
he calls him an idiot
i just get major major major
uh
what's it called
venom vibes
you
the classic
marvel incognito starter pack put the
hood over the head
put the cap on put the sunglasses on
and no one will ever spot you that way
and here is ethan hawk who i think does
a phenomenal job
i mean look at him that's just
that's the crazy cult leader is what
that is and i freaking love it
for those of you wondering yes we are
watching it
we're 13 minutes into it
and we're watching uh
ethan hawk is arthur be a cult leader
trying to show you arthur there he is
and he does oh he does such a good job
he's so good
excuse me
this part makes you feel like you have
insomnia
that's funny
i feel like i know that actor but you
don't really get a good look at him
green is good
[Laughter]
oh god you guys are good
you must have been talking about wendy
when he does all the
rubik's cube stuff and stuff like that
i just know she caught him harrow oh
because he's arthur harrow
i've been pronouncing that name wrong
think i've been saying harold
everything
you
on kit raj i accidentally timed you out
and i'm sorry i did not mean to
it will not last long i apologize
i do not undo it though
nothing
this part so good
it's so good
laughs
[Laughter]
i'm trying to stop my limbs from moving
oh i love that
i love that
nobody's like i'm just i'm just gonna go
laughs
oh yeah that's such a good part
[Music]
i got 35 year old man who doesn't have
his license
this is a
car chase scene that's been shown in the
trailers
he's being chased right now
here they come
and this lady's uh gonna be extra nice
to him right here
thank you i'm sorry
but she ain't having it
[Music]
i like this park because he's throwing
he stroke cupcakes at him
awesome
oh i love that
[Laughter]
my cat yeah she's right there
hahahahahahaha
[Laughter]
the cupcake
episode one is
47 minutes
oh
that would suck
i like how this shot right here is like
he's kind of split in the mirror
what up brandon gibson we are back
uh see you one day
see you guys
thanks for stopping by i appreciate it
we'll have to get together in a stream
sometime soon
what do fishies dream about
laughs
is that normal
[Laughter]
the nemo movie
fish is wrong time is wrong
you're wrong
this guy you just like you like him so
much
and just bad things happen to him and
you just feel so bad for him
not looking so good is it i love how he
says that
poor guy
punchy
ah this guy
really
this poor guy
uh just one episode today guys
the best bit
oh no
if i sat down with somebody like this
and they and they order order just like
like this i would laugh so hard
and be embarrassed
but since he's a vegan
hey enchantrix yeah go ahead attack me
i'll uh i'll keep a lookout for it
sometimes it doesn't tell me when people
tag me in things and sometimes it does
but i'll look out for it late as gay as
i
i know circular right
i just
the latest gay is with his mom is like
it's like such a sweet thing
and you just want you like want to root
for the guy you just want him to win in
life
and he's just a guy down on his luck
unfortunately
now he's back to his apartment
it's flat
what's up benjamin um
yo jd ultra what's up
bully mcguire
uh there is blood in the show
we've seen blood in the show already
some sprinkles
i'm not i don't have a fish
but i don't think you're supposed to
feed fish chocolate sprinkles
and i'm not a veterinarian
oh but i'm just going to throw that out
there
ezra the cosmic midner
moon nighter bender
oh secret secrets
he's still got sprinkles on his face
aha
the part we've seen in the trailer
layla
i'm going to champ frenchy
i love it i love that it's a motorola
i think motorola right razor like
yeah all right
uh
apart from each other where he he has
the phone
and
where is like what you call me mark
why did you call me mock
they are gone they are long gone but
he's got a a razor in this and then
we've seen it in the trailer too
which i guess
guess they don't ever say when this
takes
place
interesting
but that's who made
the the razor right the motorola made
the razor right
hey what's up amen sing
okay this would high key creep me out if
i was like
alone in like a really
poorly lit place
and that
ah thanks derek appreciate that don't
know if it's sarcasm or not but i
appreciate it
this stuff i like i like stuff like this
this is cool
i like the music
i like the music
uh yeah it's it's up
it's like checking to see if it's real i
love it
what's up louis patino
it's that right now we're watching the
part that's already been shown otherwise
i wouldn't show it but
i guess you can't really see it because
there's a big reflect there we go
super creepy
i love it
hey what's up jason nathaniel how's it
going
i love how freaked out she gets
and
i love how everyone looks at him
uh old channel
i've explained in a few videos but yes i
will eventually
probably within a couple of weeks talk
about that
because i do believe this will set up
the midnight suns
uh if if it didn't it wouldn't make
sense it makes perfect sense to set it
up
what's up nikhil verikar
what's going on
i'm glad you like it spiridian studios i
i really like it
levi says bruv
it's free
oh
this bus sucks
that's creepy
yo what's up jersey the king i'm good
how are you
what's up gabriel greetings back to
costa rica
that personally love it
for those trying to find it on disney
plus actually search for moon knight
don't just uh like scroll for it on the
browse section you got to type it in
everyone's in on it
hey thanks gabriel appreciate that we're
all chilling
dude he does such a good job
ethan hawk
he's so creepy
[Laughter]
he's so creepy i love it
oh he's so perfect for the both of these
guys are perfect for their parts
perfect
what's up waterboard kitty thanks so
much appreciate it
kathy can you not watch it on disney
plus
love it chills
i would be so freaking out right now if
this if that was happening to me like
iro
oh thank you
jersey the king i super appreciate that
chaos
love it thank you i appreciate that
comments like that help me
push on they really do
yeah search it kathy you gotta search it
uh it probably won't pop up just like in
the in the browse feed under marvel
hey thanks eight
hakugi ho kiki sorry about that
appreciate that
god this guy
you just ah gosh you just feel so
bathroom because he's such a sweet guy
you just want him to win
you want him to win in life
i want him to have a better boss
so real r
reeler i thought so too for that for
that uh like truck scene i i was like uh
it's pretty
that was kind of weak
i'd agree with you on that
everything else is pretty good
marvel plus shang chi shong chi versus
moon knight
depends the chance you have the rings
if he has the rings i think he wins if
he doesn't have the rings i think
midnight wins
ah thank you circular appreciate that
i'll do my best
uh just the first episode dean
and we're about done so let's
let's watch
such a good actor oh
stephen
grant
love how he stops to do that
i do know issues we are actually teaming
up soon for a video
i think a lot of people will be excited
for that oh this part's cool
oh that's so cool
that's so intense
that i like that part a lot
i think the suit looks so good and there
it is
no post credit scene
no post credits scene all right
what did everybody think
what up marvel plus
reply again uh the runtime is like 47
minutes but you know how these disney
plush shows are they like to
put six minutes five minutes of uh
of credits right so all right hold on
let's get the friends in here what did
everybody think
for those of you who just watched it
what did everybody think i'm really
curious to hear everyone's thoughts
good day man i'm glad you loved it
uh rustine fabro i mean would i prefer
man thing i think they could bring him
in
uh
you
know uh this episode was really good um
i don't think it's like a 10 out of 10
because it is like an intro episode
but i love how i just i love
how the show is of the vibe of it i love
the feel of it i love the the darkness
of it like when he's in the hallway and
the lights are flickering and all that
stuff like that like i i really like it
i i just really really like it okay so
uh let's get chris
and miss alley cat in here how do i do
this like
i always forget
wait no this is the wrong one
this is the right one
this is the right one okay
we need like a t hello christopher
hey it's el warno
uh
i gotta see if people can hear you
we need to invent a new tier system
a new tier system
yeah like i don't like one through ten i
think hold on real fast
okay people can hear you
people can hear you everybody say hi to
see we didn't break up we love each
other
it's true
they just moved across the country to
get away from me
the rumors were false we still love each
other
were there rumors
a plus ah we could do a plus minus
that's not i guess you could i guess you
could rate abcdef
because like and then do my and then do
plus or minuses that's probably a bit
more
accurate gives you like a better idea
because nobody ever gives it lower than
a six and it's like yeah that's like a
good part of the scale yeah cody says hi
warren hi
good morning ali says hi warren hi
loved it
is there what cameras happening
uh we can try if you want um
or we can do it next week cole woof
already better than hawkeye yes it is
i enjoyed hawkeye but it wasn't the best
disney play show just gotta be honest i
liked hawkeye better than what if
but this is well on its way
this this is uh
and that's what i keep saying people
keep asking me like hey is this your
favorite disney plush show i i gotta see
how it ends
i i've only i haven't seen how it ends
right it's gonna be hard
to beat loki
it
or eve i was saying this before it
started
it's so hard to compare one division
logie and this
it's like here warren i was saying this
exactly alex like eat this apple pie
eat this steak
which one was better they're like
they're just so
different they're just different things
yeah i i guess i write it on my
enjoyment factor
that's a good way to try to like i guess
like do it
like maybe you enjoy steak more than you
enjoy apple pie right exactly so
different and they've done such a good
job individualizing each series
like i have to credit them the one thing
i really like about this is
as far as the individualizing like
you're talking about
i
besides the marvel logo
how would you know it's a marvel show
exactly right if you have like zero idea
who moon knight is
how would you know
i think it's a really good first episode
i think if you if you like this episode
you're really gonna like the next one
and then you're really gonna like the
next one and then you're really gonna
like the next one so if you like this
episode you are in for a treat and moon
knight might be your new favorite series
yeah
it's fast-paced
it's it's individualistic that's
actually what i like about it it's super
fast fast-paced
yeah somebody was like in my chat like
whoa we're already seeing mark it's like
oh yeah no this is go time like we're in
like
we saw everybody kanchu mark like
everything was showing up already we got
a couple more to introduce but like it's
go
let's go
um but no to build off exactly what
you're saying about like the marvel
studios logo another thing that makes
this show very special
is there's zero connection
to anything that's happened like there's
no wanda
or thanos or blip or spider-man or dark
like it's completely his own slice of
marvel that will eventually lead into
other stuff right hopefully we're
talking midnight sons and maybe avengers
who knows where he's gonna head
but at the moment it's its own thing and
it's been a long time since we've had a
fresh
new thing that's just on its own in
marvel so it's super awesome
yeah true i agree um
i want to reply to this because i
i relate to this uh morgan studios as
someone that doesn't watch horror i
think this had just the right amount of
horror if you know what i mean i do
because i don't watch horror either
[Laughter]
so i know what you mean okay we're gonna
try new rating system here um guys if
you spam i will time you out and if you
come back out of timeout i will ban you
that's just how it is
ban hammer i don't want to do it i don't
want to but this needs to remain
enjoyable for everybody
uh
so
we're gonna try a new rating system here
not one through ten listen to one not
one through ten you know what actually
no way
okay way more than i was going to say if
you a plus minus if you add all that up
is it 10 no it's not it's more than 10
now um
rate this a
plus two f minus listen to his streams
you know what he's saying a plus to f
minus
rate it what did you think of the first
episode
he said a plus to f minus rate it
alligator a plus i honestly this first
episode it's a plus they didn't miss
and every i've seen it what probably
three times now that for three times
maybe yeah four third time
like for me
he oscar isaac is perfect there's nobody
really there's nobody that could have
done better yeah oh here they come hold
on they're they're they're coming in
josh robnett 100 out of 10. that's
pretty good hold on this is easy just
want to say
this comment pretty good display of
oscar isaac's acting range i agree i
like how it's like to two different
people and it gets better
100 i
got a plus from jake
i've got an s plus from t which i guess
is supposedly higher than a i've only
seen one thing below a b
and
it's a f minus
an f minus i'm curious why why the guy
that put f minus or the woman that put f
minus
y f minus
yeah sue
[Music]
thank you for the super chat welcome
back
thank you thank you thank you
a plus for sue
all right love it
love it love it love it love it welcome
back so and i appreciate the the super
chat
very much
that's crazy it seems like most people
are are in now it seems like most people
are pretty excited yeah so i want to i
want to comment jersey the the king i
agree i think ethan hawk
was perfectly cast for this part the
crazy cult leader that's also kind of
charming at the same time which
i think and i say this on my breakdown
makes him even
like more dangerous right mm-hmm
i love it
i love
uh esro k for konchu
k for god k for [ __ ] that character the
voice is perfect
i love this yeah the series is good man
we got so much awesome stuff coming with
this and it's going to get us to cool
places yeah um braun um
i'm sorry i don't know
umbra and one ma
as a long time moon knight fan this is
exactly what i wanted so freaking high
for the rest of the show if you guys
like this episode it they just get
better
which is something i can appreciate
about a series is that the episodes get
better because sometimes they don't you
know like let's be honest like you get
sometimes they have like fillers yeah
i was just about to say that sometimes
filler episodes and [ __ ] i had a couple
hawkeye was pretty slow for me not gonna
like this is so fast-paced yeah not
gonna lie guys uh should we take a
second to talk about
bruno we don't talk about bruno chris no
no no never i wouldn't i wouldn't dare
talk about bruno come on but and alec
and ali and i were talking about this a
lot
the music selection
is oh it's so good but works so well
nothing matches but it freaking works
it's so good they're sitting there in a
car chase scene and some guy just got
shot in the head and wake me up before
you go get so perfect
i did notice that you can see the like
blood coming out of the guy's head
uh yeah it's hard yeah eight
hokage thank you for the super chat
appreciate it boys this i'm glad that
you liked moon knight it is awesome uh i
i liked it
aj xyla aka deadpool deadpool love that
thanks for the super chat the person uh
who gave it an f minus must be a dc fan
[Laughter]
i don't mind people giving it an f minus
i just like to know why i would like to
know why yeah yeah yeah i don't you know
you like what you like anytime i do like
you right like it's too scary for me and
i could completely get that like
marvel's notoriously kind of upbeat yeah
different vibe and this is a whole
different direction yeah for sure
for sure uh the voice of khan shu a lot
of people are like oh that sounds
familiar it sounds like venom right i
mean it's literally venomous
i wouldn't be so it's not uh tom hardy
they uh
the the the voice actors in the credits
i i can't remember his name right now
apologize to the voice actor but um
excellent job
oh sue thank you that cute comment was
directed towards me thanks
um
yeah it is i that's a good word to use
andron uh trippy
i i like it
i like trippy
uh trip it's a journey yeah i i really
like trippy and
the next one gets pretty trippy the
mirrors are cool right
the mirrors are cool the mirrors are
really really really cool so
uh yeah guys if you spam
i'll time you out
i'll time you out i'll do it
i'm worried about mr anderson he wasn't
here tonight
i'll have to hit him up jeff aikido
welcome back dude
thanks for the super chat
love it how does this character look
like david and f probably also hate
chocolate
love it how does this character tie to
the mcu
uh we're gonna see
um
we're gonna see because they do
a good job at uh
not tying it
do you
know what i mean in the first uh you
know episodes
they they they do a really good job
i think this i think the series is good
um because i think
marvel
should have a side i say that very
specifically not they should go in this
direction entirely but should have a
side that is a bit darker that's a bit
grungier because they have a lot of
characters that are that way blade
moon knight ghost rider the punisher
daredevil like
these people need to come into the mcu
moon night is a great start to go down
that path
um and
i just i love steven grant the guys i
just like
so he's lovable he's a lovable person
and the whole entire time i'm like i
hate everybody who hates this guy i hate
his boss steven grant is like i like
this character so much
i like it uh moon knight oh i got i got
a super chat from the moon night
i really wish they used the first teaser
theme for the show that one was so good
but either way i thought it was a solid
episode anymore uh i can't remember if
they used that in one of the other
episodes
or if they just use that for the trailer
but i think the music is like
it's like chris said like it's random
but it works
it works
uh like it starts with bob dylan
um
and i don't i just i like bob dylan so
it works
fun all around yeah jersey the king
thanks for another super chat i think
this is one of ethan's best roles ever
yeah just just wait till you keep
watching like i i think it's uh
they all get better as they go yeah
they all do they just build on each
other
yeah it's really good
i wonder if this has a reincarnation
aspect um
you'll see
i keep hesitating too
what one thing i don't like about like i
like this is gonna sound weird and
stupid
uh no i i know exactly what we're gonna
say i i don't want to see so many
episodes in advance
yeah because then it's like because then
i know we get to
enjoy the reveal with everybody right
that but then i know
because a big part of what i do is
theorize on what could happen when it's
like what they do
i know
they're like how about we just give him
all of the episodes and he can't say i
think that was disney's plan
he keeps guessing the whole thing the
dude like for a loki i said kang is
coming after the first episode and like
the entire time i'm like here comes king
who can here comes kang like and then it
was like kang
now they're like
just show him the episode so he like
can't say it
so it's a move it's a move yeah so
avatar the anime mcu cannon i think so
who wins in a fight moon knight vs ghost
rider ghost rider
definitely that goes better
uh dang third eye production try um
searching it don't like find it in your
browser but uh tr try searching it
is disney going to buy avatar anime that
i don't i don't really know i have no
idea that is outside my scope that's
above my pay grade
uh
i'm gonna try to pronounce this right
i don't think i am
um we definitely
am biff
how would you c-y-m-r-u
simrow simru
slime room submarine
i'm so sorry i'm just butchering the
heck out of this but thank you for that
super chat he says oh boy what an
amazing show bravo kevin you kevin kevin
knows what to do
kevin really knows what to do i uh
i fully trust kevin feige i don't think
he would ever
let something air that wasn't up to his
standards whether that's a movie or tv
show or a promo or a trailer or
something like that i just don't think
that's
that's not who kevin is kevin has to do
you know
good things
that are up to his standards which is
why he's the president right i mean he's
an awesome guy
who's ready from a fish though
mafishto
thanks for another super chat i can see
mark and wade wilson hanging out on
screen
that actually be pretty cool they both
got mouse
so that would be pretty cool
why is this thanks for dirt the chat
imagine doctor strange open a portal and
go straight to debut by norman reedus
from twd or nicholas cage
i
i i like low-key high-key really want
nicholas cage to return his ghostwriter
just throwing that out there yeah i
think it would be so one of these days
before dr strange come out we're just
gonna have to sit down and just list
every like logical possibility who we
could see well the problem is there's so
many logical possibilities like we
should literally just sit down and with
chat just be like all right like who
could actually show up like
everyone go
literally literally i could show you 100
characters i could show up
like i'm not spoiler alert i'm not in
multiverse madness that i know of
taking footage from
[Laughter]
the variant of me that has a dc channel
is
[Laughter]
terrifying
no
but anyways i
i like this series a lot so far
i have been like trying
not to say
the first episode is very much a
introductory episode
but now that you have all seen it
uh i think you can tell it was uh
introducing us to stephen grant
and
the next episode will be more about mark
spector will be more about moon knight
and
thank you for stopping by yeah
thanks for stopping by and then after
that they'll get even deeper into it
deeper into uh
the whole egyptian ancient egypt side of
it um
and it gets really good it gets really
really really good and it seems like
everybody really really
enjoyed this show enjoyed the first
episode which i'm like super excited to
see because i enjoyed it
and i always wonder like am i crazy for
liking some things or you know
what do we do yeah i know
it's nice though i think the perfect
word for this this series right now is
refreshing it's a different direction
it's a different tone it's different
stories
it's super fun that marvel's coming out
with a new title character for a marvel
series on disney plus like they're
taking big risks and so far i think
they're paying
true yes uh
i feel like with kevin feige not much as
a risk
that's true and it always comes back to
the same thing you know in phi gee we
trust and
at the end of the day marvel just
doesn't really miss like they usually
hit their intended mark their intended
goal like even with what if a lot of
people didn't enjoy it as much but what
if is everything that it was supposed to
be it was supposed to be and there are
definitely people there who loved it but
it wasn't supposed to be you know some
type of groundbreaking it's supposed to
be an addition to open up the idea of
the multiverse to get us ready for dr
strange it was an enjoyable show
yeah but for me i don't know why
when it doesn't affect things i tend to
not really care
yeah and that's what marvel's at right
now is that
that it has to connect it has to make
sense which is why moon knight's so
brilliantly done because we're sitting
here talking about where it will connect
and we know it will but it doesn't
immediately
yeah and that's the thing is fighties
already come out and said like they all
connect you gotta watch disney plush
shows like yeah most of them are gonna
appear in movies
so east coast sniper thanks super chat
the midnight suns are on the horizon my
friends i agree with you yes yes yes yes
yes i agree
um
eighth
hokage why marvel because i love marvel
and i know the most about it
uh
when i started the channel i was talking
about dc and i know a fair amount of dc
but i you know i admit that i don't know
as much dc as i do marvel uh when it
comes to comics i'll be specific about
that um i've read a lot more marvel
comics than i've read dc uh
but as far as like the dc eu like what's
on screen i'm all up to par with that
and uh you know maybe we'll work dc and
i've been working star wars in a little
bit i'm really excited for the ob1 show
uh
really excited for that show vader
coming back here oh man uh but i love
marvel um
i geek i've always just geeked out to
marvel the most i've always just liked
the characters the most
so i will address this
jdee
some spots of the cgi looked uh when i
first saw that truck scene that had like
all the logs in it
i was like that's bad cg
i was like that's not a that's not the
best but i but they save it for other
things is like remember there's a budget
for everything right so some things
unfortunately
same thing happens in some movies like
get kind of like uh we're gonna make
this look a little bit bad because like
who cares
like who cares if the truck that was
holding all the logs didn't look you
know like 8k real and stuff like that
you know what i mean
but i will say that
i did like it takes a lot for me to go
oh that's some off cgi and it did hit me
with that on that one so
it did uh uh who was the animal like
creature at the end uh that is an
egyptian jackal
an egyptian jackal
so one thing i like about the show
though is that like
a lot of people are saying like oh you
know he's freaking he's bad a like yeah
he is he's freaking
cool right like this is a
it's gritty right it's not so and like
it's not so family-friendly i think
that's really appealing to a lot of
people right
it's it's it's grunge and i really
really like it moises thanks for super
chat dude appreciate that
captain america hydra and the human
torch by chris evans on doctor strange
boulder vs madness toby
zombie one zombie strange yeah i hope
man um
how crazy would it be if you saw chris
evans as captain america hydra and then
the human torch that'd be pretty
freaking cool
yeah
chris evans just starts popping up all
over the mcu with different characters
that's like his new thing right so like
stan lee used to pop up yeah right now
yeah
no yeah
um dang no it's awesome and i honestly
i'm just excited like you've said we've
seen it so it changes a little the
dynamic of our opening premiere night
but it is exciting to see how much
everybody's enjoying it and they are
but i've seen very little bad feedback
so far
yeah so super excited that just means
the next watch party is going to be even
more hype and the hype will continue to
grow almost kind of like one division
like those were the days
yeah one division watch parties were
special like it just got bigger and
bigger those were something and
especially because it was the first so
that was like really really cool yeah
that was very strong yeah jd it did like
i don't care that that cgi wasn't that
good in that part it doesn't bother me
at all
all the other cgi's really really
fantastic and the moon night like
costume is so cool because i got to see
it in person and the way that like they
go between
it being an actual costume and a cgi
like thing is like really good it's
fantastic
fantastic
ritwik the best marvel show for used
daredevil well let's see what moon
knight does for you i'll see if it uh
makes it uh
gives it a run for its money really want
to watch all the episodes moon night hey
same here i really want to know how it
ends because i think that'll determine
of course it'll determine like where
it's ranking is for i mean moon night is
dark well wait till the next episode
space god
uh yeah
uh what's the best marvel movie show for
me uh the best movie
i don't ever count in game and infinity
war because they're so good i put them
in there and they're like these huge so
it's so good i put them in their like
own category
because they're just so good uh so if
you take them away probably ragnarok
shang chi after ragnarok those two are
those two are pretty much up there and
shows right now loki is my favorite show
right now so
hey quincy charles thank you so much ah
you've been since one division so you
know the good times how crazy it was
then and thanks for becoming a member i
appreciate it
uh there are six
episodes total uh for moon night for
those of you asking
and we have a
[Music]
uh
oh sue i didn't realize that
they didn't have it in korea at that
time
uh to join the watch parties here in one
division is that was that why
because it wasn't in korea yet oh dang
well we're here now we're here they just
they just announced it for south africa
oh yeah yeah i saw that actually yeah
yeah
still not everywhere yet but hopefully
everybody can join in soon on all the
fun yeah that's uh
that's what i hope i hope everybody can
in some way shape or form like through
hot start as well as whatever it may be
uh i can continue into this new plus and
i hope it releases at the same time for
everybody
because i don't know i don't know if
that's
i i don't know if it releases at
different times for
you know other countries and stuff like
that i actually don't know
but uh
i want to ask one more time since it's
been a little bit since we asked this in
the chat we have some new people here
now what do you rate this episode before
we get off i wanna hear it again we're
gonna go from a plus to f minus not the
one through ten a plus to f minus what
do you rate the very first episode of
moon night
and
go
oh quincy you're in the united arab
emirates at the time
did you
[Music]
did you
get it when you were there you always
use a vpn
i guess yeah anybody could use a vpn
skye chung thank you very much i
appreciate that
a minus b plus a a plus b plus b oh a
lot
there's a c there's a c let's see i got
an a i'm getting a lot
all a's and b's except for that one c
if you rate it below a b let me know why
i got a b plus everyone just had their
own opinion i would never say you're
stupid for thinking that i would never
say that but i i would like to know why
i got an a plus meow
ooh meow meow
wow that's like super hydrating
another a plus
i got all a's and b's over here yeah
quincy used a vpn there you go i got a f
y oh another f
let's just test curved
[Laughter]
hey billy book news what's up gotta be
from john adkins oh no curve the test
sword that's funny
oh you said jk he said jk a
person who said f
oh it was a troll galaxy w
w that's a good rate yeah moises if i
hear a voice in my head i'll be like
let's do this
he was really
really fighting
huh yeah you have to wonder though you
like really have to wonder because it's
also like he wakes up in like
a new play like he goes
gets in his bed and then he wakes up
somewhere new then you're hearing a
voice in your head it's like what the
hell
i always think i was going crazy thanks
for the super chat aaron thanks for the
super chat episode was amazing 9-10
can't wait for more
well i will say
uh
see made you look especially nay i will
say the people who
uh
really
liked
this episode
it's just gonna you're better gonna like
the next one more and if you didn't like
this one so much you're gonna like the
next one more
uh mitchell perez think it was a super
chat what has been my favorite premiere
to attend safar easily spider-man no way
home it's
gonna be really hard to top that one uh
yeah it's that one's gonna be hard to
top
hopefully i get invited to multiverse
and madness you never really know
um
because it is like
they only have certain amount of slots
right and if like a bunch of celebrities
come in and they're like i need 50
tickets then they get 50 tickets so you
never really know
they really know
but spiderman no way home by far uh
heroes playbook thank you for that super
chat what if they reveal the avatars for
the other egyptian gods uh i hope they
do
i really hope they do um
the
dang it how do you pronounce this
the
the group of gods
the helio
politicians heliopolitans uh
and bast the black panther god is one of
those as well i hope they do reveal
avatars for them
so
cool yeah it's a cool theory to add to
the mcu especially with thor 11 thunder
coming up
where they are going to start
introducing these gods presumably you
know with gore the god butcher and a
whole different dynamic of you know the
cosmic side of marvel and if they all
can select avatars in that same way
it could be really interesting
yeah
that's that long cgi was worse some
people are gambling about uh the cgi but
um i didn't
i haven't noticed anything besides that
truck
that way and i saw the first two
episodes on a very
large theater screen
at the school too where were you at the
tlc chinese theater no el capitan ldl
capitan yeah
very good screen i didn't notice you
know really really bad things all right
i have a 30 minute video to edit
yes
and i have a mom we're probably going to
guys
cause it's four o'clock in the morning
it's 2 a.m for me and i still have work
to do as well but we got to get to the
grind i'm really glad everybody liked
moon night
for the most for the most part and for
those who didn't uh stay stay with it
because it gets better i i think from
here well it's the first episode so from
here on out doesn't really mean anything
but
each episode after this is gonna get
better and better better my own personal
opinion um and hopefully the finale
really really pays off so let's end the
super chats because i'm about to end the
stream oh yeah one two guys
aryan seagull
thanks for super chat i really wanted
mark to say embrace the chaos at the end
but what an entry damn yeah uh i'm
hoping he's saving that you know for
like a really maybe in the finale or
something like that like maybe we'll get
that um i'm kind of waiting for him to
start you know
cussing at people like
like blade and morbius and stuff like
that and
dracula and you know uh like so
we'll see but hey thanks everybody for
stopping by uh
so
next week
i might be a little late
i have a very late hockey game and it is
a playoff game
oh
so i can't miss it
well dang so
y'all just wait we'll have the
discussion for sure
but i might be i'm i'm going to be home
pretty late
but hopefully
not not that late so
if i if i'm
a little late just wait i'll be back so
all right everybody thanks for joining
today everybody say goodbye to chris
uh be sure to check out cosmic culture
that's his channel and marvel minute
news which is ally's channel who yeah i
don't know if she was here
i think she's got to go up on her own
discord after we'll figure that out we
gotta get cameras and
yeah yeah yeah somehow we still don't
have that all figured out yeah see
pranav you know it you watched you've
read the comments pranav that's what i'm
glad everybody had a good time in my
chat as well it seems like everybody had
a good time so be here again next week
people in warren's chat be there again
next week too
and uh let's keep having fun it's great
love the live streams appreciate all of
you so much appreciate the super chats
the normal chats the people watching in
the background love it all we're all
here in the same community
it's
great it's a great community so we'll
see you next week and the breakdowns
will come out in a few hours so if
you're still up look for that if not
when you wake up look for that as well
so uh
we'll see you next week woof